was macht der zombie da links ich glaub
und jetzt hat er auf sich zu drehen
schön also stellte seine beschreibungen
sextäter sich wieder nein leute nur weil
pc im titel steht heißt das nicht dass
mein neuer pcs gerade auch davon dass
ich gerade mit dem aufnehmen und nein
nur bei facetime im titel steht heißt es
auch nicht dass gerade die face kam am
start ist so erst mal hallo und herzlich
willkommen zu einem zu einer runde
meinen sie bei mir gerade um 23 uhr 11
mitten in der schulzeit für mich ist das
nicht besonders spät allerdings kennt
meine eltern schon deswegen bitte weg
von mir kontakt ja okay dann lohnt sich
jetzt gehofft ein kompliziertes der
stadt
ok danke ganz kurz was sagen und zwar
nutze ich diese runde hier jetzt bzw
wollte ich nutzen um so ein bisschen
quatschen allerdings gaben 8 ich glaube
ich hab's news lightning und den ganzen
quatsch noch gar nicht an
ich weiß gar nicht ob tief bei noch gar
nicht erweitert
millionen einig dass darauf also moment
maximum so ersetzt ich weiß nicht mein
pcs der allerschlechteste dienst gibt
offen
deswegen wird es wahrscheinlich haken
und alles mögliche allerdings deswegen
steht der kauf neuer pc titel zwei wenn
ihr dieses video fahrer dieses video
gerade seht ist voraussichtlich für eine
menge zombies hinter mir
er ist voraussichtlich gerade das ist so
mehr ich dachte schon da werden die welt
abgeschnitten voraussichtlich bis ich
weiß das heute freitag ist und die haben
gestern e mail gesendet der pc laden bei
dem ich den pc gestellt habe und der pcs
da und heute ist er freitag und heute
ist auch noch der monitor angekommen
weil ich mir auch noch neuen samsung
monitor bestellte bei der imac wahlen
desktop-pc das heißt wenn ich den weg
gäbe ist mein monitor dementsprechend
auch weg und deswegen bis heute beides
angekommen das heißt ich werde heute an
noch abholen wird dann wahrscheinlich
mit simon aufnehmen am samstagnachmittag
und dann also morgen nachmittag und dann
kommt morgen dann in folge fließt wenn
meine neuen pc mit besserer power et
cetera sind die ganzen bis jetzt
überhaupt noch hinter mir all das hat er
mir also das gibt es erstmal zu den pc
zu sagen und was es sonst noch so zu
sagen gibt es das mit face cam habe ich
ja ganz im titel geschrieben heißt nicht
dass die fei scam drin ist denkt ihr
euch bestimmt so hell aber du wolltest
doch wenn du fest gewinnt apple schreibt
sonne face cam drin aber da haben dann
wohl wieder wenn das jetzt einige von
euch denken haben wir dann wohl nicht
richtig zugehört
weil ich habe gesagt wenn ich in eckige
klammern camp schreibe weiter das zeige
ich demonstriere ich gleich mal hier im
chat wenn ich die ganzen zwei sätzen
besiegt hat mit typisch like gekommen
so alle tot wenn sowas im titel steht
dann ist es mit face cam
aber wenn ich irgendwie hinter schreibe
blablabla strich face cam dann dann ist
face käme das thema so wie jetzt gerade
und ja also das ist das einzige worüber
ich reden wollte und viele leute also
mein video wo ich mich gezeigt hat
glaube ich jetzt 80.000 und 90.000
aufrufe fast eine menge ist weil ich
habe hundert tausend abonnenten und ich
hätte nie gedacht dass das so oft
angeklickt wird
und naja sache ist allerdings die dass
eine menge leute mich jetzt gerade
drängen zurzeit per nachrichten per
google mail dass ich doch endlich real
live videos machen soll
allerdings ist dass man noch meine
entscheidung also face cary elwes werde
ich da machen aber es kämen jetzt immer
noch meine entscheidung gar nicht sie
reinpacken kann nicht weil jetzt auch
gerade wo ich aufnehme ich sitze hier in
tanktops ich hab eine nachricht bekommen
okay ich hab grad in tanktops zum
beispiel so halb nackt und habe meine
haare auch nicht gemacht und hätte bis
fünf mädchen einspart aber die sache ist
dass ich im grab vorsitze
und ich fühle mich gerade einfach nicht
will man sich wenn man einfach viel zu
müde um den kamera zu gucken weil ich
habe heute vier stunden klausur
geschrieben englisch also wenn ihr
dieses video seht gestern welchem es gab
am donnerstag auf allerdings habe ich
wirklich eine menge gelernt dafür und
vier stunden klausur schreiben ohne
essen und getrunken habe ich habe ich
mein essen einfach vergessen ist schon
krass
sobald ein ende august durch zum
exportieren oder davon dann kann ich oh
[ __ ]
mist wasserflasche können jemand der
offen
wenn ich irgendwo wasser sehen
naja allerdings ist dann folgende sache
jetzt erst mal dass ich quasi heute fiel
gestern vier stunden klausur geschrieben
habe und darf habe ich eine menge
gelernt und dann habe ich auch noch am
dienstag habe ich drei stunden latein
klasse geschrieben lief eigentlich ganz
gut war ich auch relativ früh fertig und
jetzt gestern am donnerstag habe ich
halt vier stunden englisch klausur
geschrieben da habe ich mir am anfang so
gedacht hey vier stunden kukksi erstmal
die ersten zwei stunden text endet dann
die aufgaben dann denkst wenn er richtig
vollzeit muss also das erste mal dass
sie vier stunden geschrieben habe vorab
möglich sechs stunden ich werde ja nicht
wissen wie das abläuft was da die
aufgabenstellung ist und ich weiß nicht
ich jetzt mehr bonndorf oder so ich bin
am anfang aus dem dorf weg gelaufen oder
die ganzen zombies waren ich glaube zwar
links aber ich sehe dahinter etwas am
horizont
ja ich glaube da läuft etwas nee das ist
eine blume nieder ganz hinunter 17
diesen stern ich weiß ich erst mal ein
stückchen jedenfalls hatte ich noch halt
schon zeitdruck und aber lief eigentlich
auch ganz gut also am ende habe ich
wirklich durchgelesen und dann gerade
als nicht fertig gelesen hatte
korrekturlesen ich rate ich wirklich
macht immer korrekturlesen ich hab
damals nicht gemacht ich dachte
bräuchten fertig abgeben schnell raus
hier
nee nee du leute ist besser wenn die
korrektur lässt weil da entdeckt so
viele fehler
eventuell welche mit stephen king machen
wir uns auf krisen vorbereitet und so
nicht so er eine woche vorher lernen und
vor sondern wie wir uns verbrächten
nicht so wie man sich vorbereiten sollte
könnte man die kommentare schreiben
das haben wollt oder ob er noch dran
seit dem ja mal interessieren was
interessiert mich in letzter zeit immer
dass meine videos am anfang angeklickt
werden dann wird zu 30 sekunden geguckt
so die szene vor dem intro plus das
intro weil das intro feiern ja viele
leute und haben wir wieder abgeschaltet
weil dann ist das so
nun konkreter videos gucken janka
kraftakt kräften
na ja und jetzt nochmal zum dritten
thema was ich ansprechen wollte
instagram ich hatte mal instagram
account instagram wenn ihr das nicht
kennt es so wie twitter nur nur für
bilder man kann dann nur bilder posten
mit zur bearbeitung und so das habe ich
jetzt auch ich heiße laser luca ich
möchte dass mich auch da als laser lokal
sprecht und nicht als solchen kräften
von crafter bin ich auf youtube
versteht ihr egal da bin ich auch noch
so locker weil instagram finde ich jetzt
ein bisschen privater genauso wie das
kitzeln noch twitter finden zum beispiel
auch keinem jahr mit luca ansprechen bei
youtube ist das so dass youtube ist so
populär
sag ich nur instagram es auch populär
bei instagram finde ich kann man so eine
diskussion reinkommen youtube.com so
viele neue kommentare sekündlich fast
schon da kann man nicht so wirklich eine
diskussion in das heißt nennt instagram
einfach luca und dann werden wir das
freunde oder erfolgen oder so das ist
auf jedenfalls erstmal oben der
beschreibung da könnt jetzt mal drauf
klicken ich weiß man immerhin und
aufzufinden mit wir wenigstens noch
einen kleinen seen der aufnahme sind
aber day die am mond geht unter das
heißt für mich es sind schon zehn
minuten des videos vergangen und es wird
langsam nacht und es wird der tag und
die zombies verschwinden wieder so ein
bisschen so also was ich jetzt so
eigentlich zusammen fassen wollte face
cam wird bald kommen also macht mir
keinen stress bitte desto öfter ihr
fragt desto länger dauert es bis die
fans camp kommt also fragt bitte nicht
mehr
dann bekommt sie auch wenn dann noch
eine sache und zwar steffen hat jetzt
auch einen kanal der heißt stefan block
also youtube.com / stefan block sollten
ohne dass es also nicht steffens blogs
und den stefan block einfach er macht
jetzt auch so outtakes und so und von
videos und so wie wir beide werden auch
eine serien und ski machen habe ich
eigentlich ist für hier geplant im
ersten video gesagt dass die serie gibt
im offenen kanal kommt allerdings gibt's
dann wahrscheinlich probleme mit den
rechten und steffen wird wahrscheinlich
irgendwann in den netzwerken nehmen das
heißt dass wir ihn komplett bei ihm
machen werden das heißt da können ja
dann abonnieren vorbeischauen und bei
mir werden mit diesem tag machen wie
schon gesagt hat oder sachen wie wir uns
auf eine klasse vorbereiten
zum beispiel liebe zum thema instagram
stehen welche spieler wir so zocken
solche ganzen videos werden wieder
machen die werden hier kommen also das
zu steffen instagram ja schon gesagt
dass ich das jetzt auch ab neuer pc roll
ich wenn ihr dieses video seht
wahrscheinlich gerade ab und nehmen dann
morgen damit auf wandern kommen auch
shader sachen und alles möglich und
einhakt dass sie nie mehr so dumm weil
warte ich habe gerade 30 fps während der
aufnahme während ich auf 40 fps
aufgenommen jetzt 61 57 das in die alles
komisch
aber es läuft zwar einigermaßen flüssig
habe ich hab die grafikeinstellungen
noch sehr gering
und ja drittes thema wald scam kommt
dann wenn ich bock ab und nun der chef
fragt desto länger dauert es also ich
werde mal ganz kriegsende auge ist das
einfach so zum 15 seconds antike safe
lock out auf [ __ ] und auskratzen burg
cancelled locker duty ruft man auch so
man kann hier einfach so drücken dann
kann man stehen bleiben kann sich aus
locken
hier ist das wohl so dass man sich
währenddessen auch nicht bewegen darf
aber ich gehe ganz gezielt um hoch und
dann würde ich sagen verabschiede ich
mich auch meine kiste äpfel können
einfach da nächstes mal bei diesem platz
vier weiter spielen mit meinem account
ich weiß ich werde ich dann wird
konkreter es schaffen weiter zu
überleben in der wildnis ist eigentlich
nämlich mal seit januar wenn ich über
etwas quatschen will wayne wie ich weiß
gar nicht ich bin auf jedem server
geschäft aufrecht direkt wieder in
meiner welt alter das sonne schnee welt
wurde die schnee textur eventuell
verändert
ich glaube die welt verändert oder da
kommt mir das mal vor ich glaube das
wird ein bisschen verändert am rand ja
das sieht besser aus
ja nee das ist einfach nur schnee darauf
auch so ok schade dass seine sachen sich
neben habe ich hier vorgestellten 1.5
update video hier ist die kollision
alter freunde wir machen das ganze zu
einer art lockt und ich werde immer hoch
klettern wird man ein bisschen was
anderes erzählen was mir sogar wieder
passiert und ich bin mir ich weiß jetzt
dass es sogar tim provision welche
mitlaufen will schaltet sich das chaos
das ist mal wieder coole sache du isst
man glatt ein screenshot man so
schreiben die dann hier auch so herr z
dttl mache alte handys aus seinem buch
kann ich habe ob tief einig darin dass
regen auf
sache ist die dass ich letztes mit
steffen auch in der stadt war
ich hab nimmt gekauft und steffen hatten
geschenke seine schwester gekauft und
wir waren in bielefeld das sage ich
jetzt noch ganz klar da brauchte ich
dann geköpft von bitterfeld haben auch
letztes anteil konkreter von dauer da
war ich aus meinem video gesagt habe
leute ich hab noch gar kein video gesagt
wo ich wirklich wohne kann auch sein
dass alles nur show versuche sind aber
naja egal wir wollen auf jeden fall
wirklich in bielefeld wir wollen nicht
in bielefeld bielefeld ist von uns zur
stunde entfernt ist auftreten 1 m
und/oder 2 stunden und so überhaupt was
na ja jedenfalls wir waren halt da und
ich hab keine angesprochen das war auf
jeden fall schon mal ganz gut weil wenn
ihr mich auf der straße seht dann könnte
ich natürlich ansprechen aber nicht
einfach nur wenn nämlich auf der straße
ansprechen und foto machen und was ihr
wollt und aber war aber nicht der herr
stock und hinterherlaufen
weil so weit will ich ihnen nicht an
dass steffen auch nicht naja jedenfalls
was ich noch sei e10 könnte steffen und
ich hoffe dass durch die straßen
manchmal kommt dass sein team an ja
hallo wir sind hier von der agentur wir
würden euch gerne fragen der jung und
dynamisch aussehen wie alt seid ihr denn
steffi 16 wörrstädter 16 ja ihr seid aus
wie 19 deswegen haben wir euch gefragt
habt ihr bei uns in wien gehabt dessen
was machen wollte aber na gut da kommen
wir später noch oft auf euch zu rücken
wir sehr cool danke hat sich nicht mal
vorgestellten wieder gesagt wo er
arbeitet aber okay hauptsache macht das
angebot bei der jung und dynamisch sind
jung dynamisch guter sind jung brutal
dynamisch alter und sein hofstaat sich
doch noch schnell hin
so sache war dann jedenfalls es wieder
weiter gehen so musste es war das lachen
bleibt waren dann noch so als in
bielefeld vorhanden
ach ja ihr wollt nicht bei subway was
essen als 100 zeit aber nicht mehr
geschafft haben uns dann einfach nur ein
eistee geholt ich warte mal ich sogar
die zeit zu überbrücken ich weiß gar
nicht schaffe ich das unbeschadet
herunterzukommen ich glaub nicht oder
nur doch das sollte ich eigentlich
schaffen
naja ich war mein leben wie es einige
wissen die mir auch bei instagram halt
folgen oder bei twitter wie staatliche
post ag auch aber dann habe ich jetzt
mein account aufgeräumt also da sind
viele fotos nie mehr fahren habe ich
jetzt noch sieben acht neun zehn fotos
oder so ich komme gar nicht durch das
eigentlich mein iphone bildschirm
letztes gerät leistet beim kuppeln namen
sky war
und da war ich auf den clown da ist mir
das handy runtergefallen als zu einer
hose war und die hose hat sich
zugeknöpft wenn das ist ja nie so
rausgerutscht und 20 zentimetern fällt
der unterschied christen und ich laufe
dann zu verkehren viele fällt und die
man so ja guten appetit durch so
erwarten jetzt ja du dort kostet 170 war
es meine mutter nein
diese wäre das traurig so herr als ob
man diese ja doch nicht wirklich scheibe
einmal 370 euro an diese neuen dann
kriegst du komplett neues und jetzt weiß
ich nicht was ich machen soll ich mir
neues holen für 317 altes dahin schicken
weil den bildschirm ist schon krass
marsch garantie braucht es kein
komplettes eigenes versagen von daher
ist das ohne volle wasserflasche ist das
bräuchte es gern mit anfang mit garantie
wälder da wird apple nicht auf
zurückkommen weil ich halt selber daran
verschuldet bin solche sind jetzt noch
ein paar sachen drin
schauen wir mal die anderen häuser ganz
kurz danach hat
freunde sind zombies
na gut ich würde einfach sagen ich mache
so man kann wenn es euch gefallen hat
dürft ihr gerne einen daumen hoch geben
das für mich auf jeden fall freuen
steffen ist in der beschreibung kann 11
abonnieren wenn instagram es in der
beschreibung könnt ihr einfach folgen
fans campen kommt das macht jetzt schon
wieder links ich glaub und jetzt hat
auch auf sich zu drehen
schön also stell mir sender beschreibung
in sex dreht sich wieder
jetzt hat er wieder auf also steffen es
in der beschreibung instagram ist in der
beschreibung face kann mache ich nur
wenn ich im endlich bock abonnieren team
aufhört zu fragen warum es ihm auf dem
dach dass ich 40 der fachmesse zu
beobachten und ein neuer pc habe ich
jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade am auspacken
wenn ihr das video gerade seht und der
zombie kommt auf mich zu das heißt ich
werde mal hier so ein bisschen mich
hinter verstecken und dann würde ich
sagen simons eventuell in der nächsten
folge meinen seid wenn ihr mir die
kommentare schreibt ob das überhaupt
noch haben wollte und ich glaube mich
jetzt aus watte 15 sekunden habe ich
noch
12.11.09 8,63